hey guys this is andrew for
trainingtences.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and i've decided
a few months ago to create
my youtube channel because guys i want
to show you everything
that i do at work to set up my trades
and to actually make money on the
markets
so i mostly do technical analysis which
is about
reading the flows and understanding how
people
react to the news so that we can predict
what might
happen in the future so today i want to
make an update
on skt tenger let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so i think i did my last
update one month ago
on the stock i followed the stock i like
the stock it looks good to me we have
beautiful situation
of breakout on the upside once again i
connect the highs that i have here
and then i'm checking if the trend line
i'm drawing is
actually acting as support which it
should be because it was resistance
or not and here what i see guys is that
the first breakout was messy
we didn't really retest this support
area in a nice way we actually blew
right through it on the downside and
then we came back but the second one
with even more associated volume is
giving me
beautiful reactions right so we break it
out
we break out on the upside and we come
back we'll be tested
then we go higher i did my video here
guys i was telling you
nice level to buy so of course could
have made an update but guys you know
this is
still true so you can see that then we
are retesting it again
at 15 so 15 was a very nice level to buy
we might see it again guys that's why
i'm doing this update
so that you can follow that i cannot do
daily updates on this
i will try to do more of course i check
what might happen so either we just
keep going higher so of course you can
see the price action is very bullish
guys we are above the 200
moving average on the four hours time
frame so here what might happen
because of course you know we are not
lifting off yet so
there is some selling pressure in this
market let's check the short interest
25 of short interest guys this is the
type of situation
where we might see a short squeeze all
right 25 is maybe
not close to 100 where we social squeeze
on gamestop for example
but it's still enough for hedge funds to
stop the position if the price action
starts
to go higher sharply so here
once again what might happen is just we
go higher
naturally but i think that we are
missing some buying liquidity all right
where is this buying liquidity sitting
guys at the 200 per moving average
so i expect something like this due to
100 moving average coming here
this downward sloping trend and that is
now as you can see guys acting as
support
very well one two three reactions all
right
this trend line has been drawn many
months ago and it's still
active and react and give us nice
reactions
so the press action might you know just
come here maybe
and then we would have this huge move up
because we need you know for this moves
up
to happen we need some buying flows to
trigger
some hedge funds maybe to close the
positions or just some
strong buying flows that are pushing the
price higher
those buying flows are not everywhere in
this market
they're sitting at at some level so we
need to go
for them so sometimes when the price is
going low it's actually good because we
go
we take this liquidity and we use it to
go higher
so this is my scenario guys i think that
around the 30s of april
so i give it like one month guys yeah i
think you have one month to
maybe take some positions if you like to
once again i don't give here advice
but this is what i would do so that's it
for me i hope you enjoyed this video and
if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys